across the country many cities have cut
the number of police officers
and reduced the funding for police
departments in response to the explosive
mass movement of protests against police
[Music]
brutality
[Applause]
uh oddly
polls show that this is not exactly what
the public wants
81 percent of black americans say they
want the police to spend
the same amount of time that they
already do in their communities
or more this may be influenced by the
overall
breakdown in law and order gun violence
in new york city has risen by 177
this july and at the same time as a rise
in crime is taking place
homelessness is also on the rise making
many locals very disturbed
it's not the city that it used to be
before march you have to take certain
precautions doesn't mean you have to be
in fear of these men doesn't mean that
all these men
are predators but a lot of them they'll
start self-pleasurizing themselves
they'll pass out on the street from k2
smoking crack shooting heroin i haven't
seen anything terrible but there have
been some murders in the neighborhood
and that
i that doesn't make me feel good a woman
was attacked in my building the other
day and it was only 10 o'clock at night
see i haven't seen anything but if i did
it would certainly bother me but i mean
just because these people should be
taken care of and obviously the rest of
us should not
be in any concern for somebody who's not
in control of himself
causing trouble if you have men with
drug problems why would you put them
into a place where there is no security
whatsoever to make sure that they don't
keep feeding their habit
the rise in crime and homelessness has
got many new yorkers fearing this could
be a return to the old new york of the
70s and 80s
many wealthy folks are packing up and
leaving
governor andrew cuomo is urging them to
change their minds
begging wealthy folks to stay even
offering to cook them dinner
you gotta come back when you're coming
back we'll go to dinner
i'll buy a drink come over i'll cook
but despite his pleading he admits new
york city is getting less
safe we're trying to get them to come
back
kovid's under control we're going to
make progress helping the homeless
we're going to clean up the graffiti
we're going to fix crime
these problems of rising crime
homelessness and violence on the streets
of new york
are something that most average new
yorkers can't afford to just pack up and
run away from
if governor andrew cuomo had given
attention to these problems that affect
lower income new yorkers then perhaps
these same problems that are now driving
the wealthy folks away
wouldn't have risen so dramatically
you